overtime and cam newton have teamed up
to give promising football players a
chance to showcase their talents the new
seven on seven football league called
ot7 it launched this week in las vegas
and here to tell us all about the action
this is overtime's chief communications
officer ben sosenko good to see you
buddy thanks so much for having us great
to be here who is playing this week and
this weekend these are the best high
school football players in the country
the elite of the elite that are going to
go on to great college careers and pro
careers and they're playing in something
called seven on seven football which is
a quick fast exciting form of football
so we'd love to see all the people here
in las vegas come out and see these
great athletes i was watching some of
the videos you guys had online and these
kids have skills here are some of the
athletes right here i mean what this guy
throws a bomb down to the end zone this
this is the future of the nfl is what we
see right here what is cam newton's
involvement with the league so cam is a
partner with us in the league and cam is
someone who's been involved in seven on
seven for years so he's had teams and he
has been a mentor to so many great
players who've gone on so he has a team
in the league he's at the field he's
cheering on he's coaching so if you come
out to to watch our uh our league you'll
see him there and you'll see his
involvement he's he's such a great
personality for us how many teams are in
the league there's 17 teams there's
about 400 players if you know anything
about star ratings 5 star is the highest
rating the elite of the elite we have 25
5 stars it's not hyperbole to say this
is the best collection of talent at this
level that's probably ever been
assembled seven on seven how's that
different than your traditional eleven
on eleven football completely different
you're right you get really besides less
players on the field less players on the
field for sure we're able to do the
subtraction but you get rid of the
offensive linemen you get rid of the
defensive lineman just receivers the
quarterback just has four seconds to
throw so there's no pass rush so you
just send out six receivers six
defensive backs and let it fly and it's
happening at the all-american park which
is on the west side of town it's
happening at all american park
completely free so
it's great completely free there's food
trucks there's other things going on you
get to be up close with some of these
athletes that like you said are going to
be the future stars of the nfl and if
you look down the list of all the top
stars in the nfl today they all played
seven on seven and they're all here now
this uh this weekend in las vegas so how
does it work so we play this weekend we
have games today we have games tomorrow
and then sunday's the big final
championship yeah so this is a league so
we're doing a regular season we started
yesterday we're doing it today we're
doing it tomorrow then on sunday is
going to be the playoffs and finals from
9am to 1pm and then we're going to be
rolling out all our content over the
course of two or three months on
overtime social channels most of our
audience is a little bit younger so they
don't watch games live on tv so they'll
be able to show us on youtube over a
couple of months your audience has
changed sure audience has changed
viewing habits have changed and that's
really what overtime is all about we're
meeting the audience where they are i
love this so now it wraps up this
weekend though we'll be back in las
vegas again next year at this time we'll
we'll see we know that we want to do
overtime and ot7 big going forward so
las vegas has been an incredible partner
so i don't see any reason why we
wouldn't want to return
it's a little warm it's all right it's
going to get warmer this is the perfect
time of year i got to wrap it up if
you're holding the official las vegas
now football look at the signature i
want to point out this is a sign by
terry bradshaw
right there yeah that's our in-house
no that's mine come on signed by terry
bradshaw ben thank you so much for
joining us thanks for having us and
again we'd love to see everyone come out
and what's the website if you want to
get more information ot7 ot scven.com i
love it have fun this weekend thanks all
right so